well hey there it's good to be back with
you all in an especially warm merry
Christmas if this is your first time
with us Adventist or otherwise so Advent
is my favorite time of year we are at a
point in the year where we're typically
focusing on the Incarnation why Jesus
did such and the major implications that
has in both the life of the church and
the world every year I try and reflect
on a different aspect of the Incarnation
this year it happened to be on Christ
life as an infant now last year we
looked at how SDA theology completely
distorts why Jesus incarnated and what
he came to do if you missed that the
link to this presentation is in the
description box down below but this year
I want to share with you how the
downstream effects of the AVST Church's
teaching around the nature of man
actually create christological heresy
and proves that the AVST Jesus is not
real but is a false Christ but to
understand it we must have a sound
understanding of the doctrine of the in
Carnation which is much more than simply
the belief that Jesus Took on a human
nature in his fourth Century book on the
Incarnation St aanus writes quote for he
did not wish simply to be in a body nor
did he wish merely to appear for if he
had wished only to appear he could have
made his Divine manifestation through
some other better means but he takes
that which is ours and that not simply
but from a spotless and stainless virgin
ignorant of man pure and unmixed from
intercourse with men men although being
himself powerful and the creator of the
universe he prepared for himself in the
Virgin the body as a temple and made it
his own as an instrument making himself
known and dwelling in it close quote now
athanasius explains his purpose in
writing this little book toward the
close of it where he states that he
sought to provide an elementary level
instruction and outline of faith in
Christ and his Divine manifestation to
us in the Incarnation and within that he
provides and defends the full full
humanity and full Divinity of Jesus
Christ which is what would later be
dubbed as the hypothetic union and his
fundamental Christian doctrine this
Doctrine states that within the single
person of Jesus Christ there exist two
distinct Natures human and divine Jesus
is not 50% man and 50% God but 100% man
and 100% God these two Natures are never
mixed they're never divided and never
confused this is derived from scripture
where we see both human and divine
attributes ascribed to the single person
of Jesus Christ he gets hungry for
example in Mark 11:12 this is a human
attribute God does not get hungry but we
also see the same Mark ascribe Divine
attribution to the same Christ such as
in Mark 2 where he documents that Jesus
forgave the sins of the paralytic that's
something only God can do as even the
Pharisees recognized in Luke 5:21 which
means it is a Divine attribute and it is
one of the key ways that Jesus
demonstrated that he is the almighty God
now early on in the church's history the
Aryan controversy took place which was a
battle over what scripture teaches
regarding the Trinity and the athanasian
Creed was formulated in response to this
while athanasius did not write this
Creed it's rightly given its name after
his staunch defense of the Trinity
during the controversy the first half of
it deals with what the Bible teaches
about the Trinity the second deals with
what the Bible teaches about the
Incarnation and the two Natures of
Christ in that second half we read quote
now this is the true faith that we
believe and confess that our Lord Jesus
Christ God's son is both God and human
equally he is God from the essence of
the father begotten Before Time and he
is human from the essence of his mother
born in time completely God completely
human with a rational soul and human
flesh equal to the father as regards
Divinity less than the father as regards
Humanity ity although he is God and
human yet Christ is not two but one he
is one however not by his divinity being
turned into flesh but by God's taking
Humanity to himself he is one certainly
not by the blending of his Essence but
by the unity of his person for just as
one human is both rational soul and
flesh so to the one Christ is both God
and human close quote so we see
something very important here about not
only the nature of Christ but also about
Humanity the Orthodox biblical Christian
teaching is that Jesus is both God and
human equally but also that the soul of
a human is rational and since Jesus is
truly and fully human in his Humanity he
also has a rational soul and this is
very very important here's why what we
believe about anthropology impacts what
we believe about christology put another
way what we believe about the nature of
humanity also greatly impacts what we
believe about Jesus since Jesus added
unto himself human nature whatever we
ascribe to the nature of humanity we are
in turn also ascribing to Jesus and this
is where we have to ask the question
when does a human become a living being
and at what point does that human
possess a rational Soul what we answer
about that we must also apply to the
Lord Jesus thankfully we can arrive at
this answer from scripture through good
and necessary deduction in Luke chapter
1 we're told that the angel Gabriel
visited the Blessed Virgin and foretold
of her giving birth to the Messiah the
Son of God he tells her that he will
take the Throne of David his reign will
know no ends Etc this is the gospel of
the Kingdom being proclaimed the message
that we see Jesus himself preaching
later in Luke 81 and elsewhere the good
news about the Messiah who would come
save a people from their sins establish
his kingdom to rule and Reign Over his
people and all of creation forever
starting in verse 34 though we can begin
to glean some details to help us answer
the question that's in Focus we read and
Mary said to the angel how will this be
since I am a virgin and the angel
answered her the holy spirit will come
upon you and the power of the most high
will overshadow you therefore the child
to be born will be called holy the Son
of God and behold your relative
Elizabeth in her old age has also
conceived a son and this is the sixth
month with her who was called baren for
nothing will be impossible with God and
Mary said behold I am a servant of the
Lord let it be to me according to your
word and the angel departed from her so
Gabriel lets Mary know that despite
being a virgin the holy spirit of God
will come upon her to conceive the child
who will be the holy Son of God but
around the same time Mary's relative
Elizabeth will also bear a child John
the Baptist now it's important to note
that what Gabriel proclaimed to Mary was
the Gospel the good news about the
person and work of Jesus if you
reference Matthew 1:21 you'll read how
the angel also said the Virgin will be
with child and he will save his people
from their sins in essence Gabriel was
sharing with Mary who Jesus is which is
his person as well as his work what he
would come and do he shared with her the
good news about the person and work of
Jesus which is the gospel and the gospel
is what the Incarnation and Christmas
are all about but then in verses 39-45
we read where Mary then visits Elizabeth
after Gabriel departs and we're given
more info to help answer our question we
read in those days Mary arose and went
with haste Into the Hill Country to a
town in Judah and she entered the house
of Zechariah and greeted Elizabeth and
when Elizabeth heard the greeting of
Mary the baby leaped in her womb and
Elizabeth was filled with the Holy
Spirit and she exclaimed with a loud cry
blessed are you among women and blessed
is the fruit of your womb and why is
this granted to me that the mother of my
Lord should come to me for behold when
the sound of your greeting came to my
ears the baby in my womb leaped for joy
and blessed is she who believed that
there would be a fulfillment of what was
spoken to her from the Lord so Mary
visits Elizabeth to let her know the
good news that was heralded to her by
the angel and when she shared this good
news with Elizabeth she was overjoyed
and said Mary is blessed amongst all
women because she would uniquely carry
the Messiah within her Elizabeth was so
Overjoyed that she even asked why she
was so blessed to have the mother of the
Lord come and share this good news with
her it's then reiterated again in verse
44 that when the sound of the good news
came Little John the Baptist in her womb
leaped for Joy which tells us that
humans become a living being at the
point of conception what was in
Elizabeth's womb was a baby and babies
are obviously living beings modern scien
has even confirm that life begins at
conception which is completely in
accordance with scripture we're told
that John the Baptist leapt for Joy when
he heard the good news of the Gospel
from the Blessed Mother well joy is
something that is experienced by a
rational being it also clearly
demonstrates that God is capable of
granting Faith to infants allowing even
them to respond to the gospel even in
the womb that is something a rational
living being does so why does this
create serious problems for Adventist
teaching in the explanation of the SDA
Church's fundamental beliefs we read the
following regarding what they teach
about the nature of humanity they write
quote when God formed from the elements
of earth a body he breathed the breath
of life into the nostrils of Adam's
lifeless body and there resulted man the
living being Genesis 2:7 this Breath of
Life is the breath of the almighty that
gives a life job 33:4 close quote then
they continue in the next page where
they write quote as we have already
mentioned in the Old Testament soul is a
translation of the Hebrew nephesh in
Genesis 2:7 it denotes human as a living
being after the Breath of Life entered
into a physical body formed from the
elements of the earth similarly a New
Soul comes into existence whenever a
child is born each Soul being a new unit
of life uniquely different and separate
from other similar units this quality of
individuality in each living being which
constitutes it a unique entity seem
seems to be the idea emphasized by the
Hebrew term nephesh when used in this
sense nephesh is not a part of the
person it is the person and in many
instances is translated person close
quote now we will get to the Hebrew word
neesh in a moment and what it means in
Genesis 2:7 specifically but notice
based on how they apply that text they
reason that all human beings are not
truly living beings until the Breath of
Life conjoins with their life body and
they become a uniquely different and
separate unit from the mother both of
those things happen upon exiting the
birth canal which would mean that until
birth a human is not actually a living
Soul or living being they are a lifeless
physical body which also means that
until the Adventist Jesus was born and
took his first breath outside of the
womb he wasn't a living being supposedly
it would mean that the hypothetic union
between the human and divine Natures did
not occur into until after Jesus's birth
and the Blessed Mother did not actually
carry the Messiah because what she
carried was not a living being it was
only his lifeless lump clay body that
she would have birthed and then that
lifeless lump of clay became a living
Soul or living being outside of the womb
but John the Baptist in the womb was not
a lifeless physical body we were told
that he jumped for Joy at the
proclamation of the Gospel about the
Messiah that clearly evidences that even
as a fetus he was a rational living
being from his very conception not after
being born taking his first breath as a
separate unit from Elizabeth and this is
the case for all of God's image bearers
which has to mean that the SDA handling
of Genesis 2:7 is incorrect because it
creates problems with other texts of
scripture including the affirmation of
christological heresy but before we can
look at the Hebrew word neesh there's
something else that has to be understood
as the athanasian Creed States and
Christians believe that Jesus is both
truly human and truly Divine possessing
both a rational soul and flesh the late
RC SPL does an excellent job of
explaining what the Creed means by this
where he said quote when we say that
Jesus has a reasonable Soul we simply
mean that touching his human nature he
is a duality he is body and soul as all
human beings are and that soul is
rational in that sense the term soul is
virtually interchangeable with the word
mind and God has created us in His image
God himself is a rational being and God
has planted within the soul or mind of
every creature that he has made in His
image the capacity for reasonable
discourse and thinking I know we live in
a time that is one of the most
anti-rational and anti-intellectual
periods of the history of the church
people love academic Pursuits
investigation and scientific inquiry but
it's the anti-m mind and anti-rational
people who think that Aristotle for
example invented logic Aristotle didn't
invent logic God did Aristotle no more
invented logic than Columbus invented
America he simply discovered and found
it close quote so when the Creed uses
the term rational Soul we could equally
use the phrase rational mind this is one
of the ways in which human beings are
distinct and separate from the rest of
creation we are made in God's image
since God is a rational being we too as
His Image bearers possess the unique
ability to engage in things like logic
and reasonable discourse something we do
not see amongst cats giraffes and whales
it's what has allowed for human
civilizations to uniquely subdue the
Earth by building skyscrapers airplanes
and rocket ships to the glory of God God
did not give commands to any other
creature other than Adam Adam received
something uniquely from God that none of
the other creatures did and God expected
Adam to use that special ability to do
what God wanted like naming the animals
and subduing the Earth Adam received a
rational Soul which is what made his
different than the rest of the creation
but this is not what the SDA church
affirms about human beings they don't
believe or teach that the soul of humans
is in any way rational or that it is a
part of what makes us distinct and
separate from the rest of the created
order as they plainly state in the same
chapter of their fundamental beliefs
Book quote when God formed the human
being from the elements of the Earth all
of the organs were present the heart
lungs kidneys liver spleen brain Etc all
perfect but lifeless then God breathed
into this lifeless matter the breath of
life and Man became a living being the
scriptural equation is straightforward
the dust of the ground Earth's elements
plus the Breath of Life equal a living
being or living Soul the union of Earth
elements with the Breath of Life
resulted in a living being or Soul this
Breath of Life is not limited to people
every living creature possesses it the
Bible for example attributes the Breath
of Life to both those animals that went
into Noah's Ark and those that did not
close quote so here we see them assert
their formula for what they think the
human soul is just like we saw earlier
the combination of the Breath of Life or
Spirit and the body until the
combination takes place a creature is
not a living soul and this isn't just
with Humanity they claim that all living
creatures possess this according to
Genesis 7:15 and 22 which means they are
claiming that the human soul is no
different than that of an iguana or a
leopard it's simply the electrical force
that is produced when the shell or body
of a creature begins breathing oxygen as
a separate unit of life but they don't
believe that the soul is rational in any
way as SDA psychology professors Carl
Bailey and Dwayne McBride note in this
paper titled The Curious Case of the
intuitive Soul AKA The Curious Case of
the rational Soul they cite the
fundamental beliefs book and state that
Adventists in no way believe that the
soul is rational man is only a living
human being when the unity of Body Mind
and Spirit are together by Spirit they
mean the Breath of Life by mind they
mean the soul which is a result of that
breath being conjoined with the human
body so adventism is one of the groups
that fit the bill for what Dr Sproul
mentioned they associate the belief that
the soul is rational with Aristotle's
School of philosophy which has to mean
that it's not biblical in any way but
ironically by that same logic Adventists
should reject logic altogether because
Aristotle is largely credited with the
discovery of much surrounding logic does
that now mean that adventism is based in
Aristotelian philosophy and not the
Bible because they try to engage in
logic and sound reasoning for their own
beliefs of course not because Aristotle
did not invent Logic the same is true
with the belief in a rational soul and I
will use Genesis 2:7 to prove as much
but as a quick note the belief in life a
conception and the Soul being rational
is a big reason why we see abortion
condemned in sources like the diday for
those that do not know the deday or the
teaching of the TW Apostles is a first
century document that contains a number
of beliefs that were normative amongst
Christians of the day in deday 2 1-2 we
read quote the second commandment of the
teaching you shall not murder you shall
not commit adultery you shall not seduce
boys you shall not commit fornication
you shall not steal you shall not
practice magic you shall not use potions
you shall not procure an abortion nor
destroy a newborn child close quote the
first century Church understood that
what was in the mother's womb is a
living rational image bearer of God and
to seek to terminate its life was to
violate the Commandment to not murder it
is the SDA belief about the nature of
man that has given justification for
Adventist being pro death what our
Wicked culture falsely calls pro-choice
and for their Affiliated hospitals to
engage in the murder of The Unborn now
with regards to the Hebrew term nefesh
which means Soul this is the central
pillar that the SDA position rests upon
like we saw in the fundamental beliefs
book appealing to Genesis 2:7 they say
that Adam became a living Soul at the
point of the Breath of Life or Spirit
entering his nostrils this is supposed
to prove that man's soul is not
something that is rational but rather
man's soul is simply the result of the
breath of life and the body coming
together the soul is the resultant life
force that all living creatures have
when the body breath combination occurs
but here's what's interesting about this
claim that they miss while the Genesis
account does indeed use the term Breath
of Life regarding more than just human
beings what the fundamental beliefs book
does not point out is that only humans
received the Breath of Life by God
himself breathing it into man so despite
the phrase Breath of Life being used of
both humans and other living creatures
what's being said about humans in this
regard is unique different and distinct
John Gil actually points this out in his
Genesis commentary he's not the only one
but he points out something important
regarding the Hebrew grammar on the
phrase and breathed into his nostrils
the breath of life he writes quote which
in that way entered into his body and
quickened it which before four was a
lifeless lump of clay though beautifully
shapen it is in the plural number the
breath of lives including the vegetative
sensitive and rational life of man and
this was produced not with his body as
The Souls of brutes were and was
produced by the Breath of God as theirs
were not nor theirs out of the earth as
his body was and these two different
Productions show the different nature of
the Soul and body of man the one is
material and Mortal the other immaterial
and Immortal and Man became a living
Soul or a living man not only capable of
Performing the functions of the animal
life of eating drinking walking Etc but
of thinking reasoning and discoursing as
a rational creature close quote so Gil
points out how the SDA fundamental
beliefs book is correct when it says
that the phrase Breath of Life is used
for more than just human beings but the
book completely misses the fact that the
Breath of Life for humans is in the
plural number which includes the
rational life of humanity John 4:24 says
that God by nature is Spirit the Breath
of Life or spirit that mankind received
was delivered directly from God who is
Spirit the other living creatures that
had the Breath of Life received such in
a different way than God blowing it into
their nostrils this Breath of Life in
Genesis 2:7 is the the rational Soul
it's why human beings including infants
in the womb are God's image Bears
distinct and separate from the rest of
the living creatures we possess a
rational soul that is able to mirror God
who is a rational being like I mentioned
earlier God uniquely gave Adam and Eve
commands with these specific commands
came a rational expectation where God
expected them to do what he said that
there was a level of understanding on
their part being made in God image and
likeness refers to the rational soul
that we possess which God uniquely
placed within Humanity it does not mean
that God physically looks like we do
which is another mishandling of the text
that the SDA Church arrives at in
Genesis this is of course at the behest
of Ellen White who very plainly stated
in the great controversy that Humanity
being made in God's image meant that man
reflected God not just in character but
in physical features and form except
like I said John 4:24 says that God is
Spirit the Son of God is unique in that
he added unto himself a human body in
the Incarnation at a certain point but
even then that happens after the
creation of humanity in Eden while it is
true that man's character was one way
Humanity mired God as His Image Bearer
this is what became tainted in the fall
but the aspect that remains intact is
our rational Soul not our physical
appearance our possession of a rational
soul is why it's still proper to say
that human beings beings are God's image
bearers including a fetus in the
womb this is one of those areas in SDA
theology where they have to have their
understanding be correct in order for
numerous other beliefs to be true in
this case 1844 and the investigative
judgment but it's also an area like the
Sabbath where they miss key details in
the text of Genesis their interpretation
and application of the text can be
falsified by testing it against other
parts of scripture John the Baptist as a
fetus jumping with joy disproved proves
that a human is only a lifeless lump of
clay that isn't a rational living being
possessing the Breath of Life as a
separate unit from his mother a lifeless
body cannot leap and experience joy in
response to hearing something proclaimed
it would mean that Jesus as a man was
not a living rational human within Mary
she simply carried around a lifeless
lump of clay in her womb and it's this
erant teaching with an adventism that
has led to a large number of Adventists
justifying abortion in including their
Affiliated hospitals where they violate
the sixth commandment and murder The
Unborn which shows us that theology does
indeed matter and what we believe in our
anthropology directly affects what we
believe in our christology Christmas is
about celebrating the Incarnation and
eternal life which is ultimately a
celebration about the gospel God coming
to Tabernacle amongst us establishing
his kingdom to rule and Reign forever as
he gradually ushers the kingdom into its
fullness it was through the Incarnation
that that the Divide between God and man
was bridged and sinners can be
reconciled to a holy God this began in
the womb of the Blessed Virgin Jesus was
a living rational image bearing human
being from conception not simply upon
exiting the birth canal and taking his
first breath make sure you spend some
time this Christmas reflecting on the
Incarnation and what that means for Our
Lives May Christ richly bless you in the
grace and peace won by him and his
vicarious death on the cross for Sinners
Merry Christmas
[Music]